passengers on a JetBlue flight say they
were terrified when armed officers
suddenly stormed their plane in New York
flashing lights surrounded the jet last
night at JFK Airport Airport it was
about to take off for Los Angeles when
the equipment failure caused pilots to
lose communication then a false alarm
triggered the massive police response
Kris Van Cleave is following this
complicated story Chris good morning
good morning that flight did eventually
make it to Los Angeles landing very
early this morning after four hours
delayed and of course just a terrifying
experience for passengers the FAA and
JetBlue are now looking into the
possibility the pilots may have
accidentally sent an alert about a
possible hijacking prompting police to
storm the plane this was the dramatic
scene at New York's JFK Airport last
night dozens of emergency vehicles
surrounded JetBlue flight 1623 after
air-traffic control lost all contact
with the pilots Alexa Curtis was on
board as heavily armed police entered
the cabin and ordered passengers to put
their hands in the air and we were on
the ground so usually this is like
happenin air if it was gonna happen
yeah people weren't ready the way
JetBlue says the Airbus a320 experienced
a radio issue impacting the crews
ability to communicate and a false alarm
was sent to JFK tower while
communication was reestablished via
alternative channels authorities
responded out of an abundance of caution
in an emergency the pilots can use the
planes transponder to signal the tower
the false alarm may have been triggered
by a pilot mistakenly entering the
four-digit squawk code for hijack 7,500
instead of 7600 which signals radio
failure former airline captain Ross
aimer this must have been something that
alerted the tower this airplane has been
either hijacked or pilots not in control
that's why you saw what that response
was
police found no security issue onboard
and gave the all-clear the plane
returned to the gate for a while while a
new crew was assigned the FAA is
investigating Gill glad everybody's okay
thank you very much Chris